I've done 291 200 calf raises in the
last decade and that comes from training
them every single day I work out four
times a week for 52 weeks for a year for
a decade now oh they just look like cabs
they were the part of my body that were
the most resistant to growth stimulus on
the contrary like I don't train my chest
at all I don't train my traps I don't
train my abs because those have never
been the constraint I've always had ABS
my traps have always been fine my chest
has always been fine and I put all of
that effort into the constraint and so
the idea is even though I have
imbalanced effort in terms of where it's
allocated the result is a more balanced
physique 291 000 calf raises later I now
have arthritis in my foot
[Laughter]